hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to boring man which oddly
enough isn't boring at all I was trying
to do an intro on the main screen and
then I got into a game oh yes please oh
god
so this game is an online stick based
battle arena and it's completely
available oh god oh hey I love love I
did not know that I was the thing and
it's completely free too
and I got a goo gun why do I Wow I'll
try the goo gun down on them I don't
know what the goo gun do how much Kumar
gonna spray oh god that's goopy oh oh
god it's melting cookie I didn't know
that it melt gooped but I'm doing pretty
good not that good but first time bling
I'll go back to the normal gun oh geez
so uh as far as things to say about this
this game has been in development for a
long time
and I'm a big fan of stick based stuff
ever since Sal's ow if that's what it's
called
Jojo and it's highly mobile home and not
mobile as in mobile game but its
mobility wise it's like really big fake
bad I can't say him a goddamn word for
those rocket Mo's oh my god the game
from behind oh man
this is a super super fun I mean
ridiculously simplistic all things
considered but oh God ah damn you know
how did he know I I mean and I don't
know how much I could possibly show you
guys except for how bad I am because I
am very bad at games but I'm also deaf
from above ah
if I scream they
Master I think if I scream I die faster
let me go into the goo gun I'm gonna
splatter you with my room green hot goo
well it's flirted but I don't think it
did anything ah oh my goood a goood all
over the place ah no get my goo get some
goo in your face that was slow ah get my
goo you like some goo whoa
you've got goood all over no one can
stop the rampaging goo ah
you gonna get some goo anybody want some
goo over here hey I got a whole glob of
goo I've been saving up for you new goo
goo
oh god goo goo I'm a baby oh god goo goo
away god I killed him somehow
I did a good thing my goood in the right
place laughs oh god I'm dead man
this is just so nuts it's suger Sturm
Nets
Oh God how did I kill him and he not
kill me because I am the gooder and I
got the better goo
I've got delicious goo for everyone to
enjoy
who wants my goo Oh someone died ah oh
God
Tony oh no I didn't know that it was you
Tony I thought that we were friends
forever
Oh God squelch squelch my face when it's
with the boats or do it
ha ha oh man hey hey go away go away go
away buddy Oh God
do you ah I got goo I'm gonna die who's
gonna die oh man
well I don't even know what the score is
Oh ooh you want some goo I got lots of
goo oh boy oh god he got me good I
wonder when I'm gonna get another weapon
I mean the rounds almost over for the
son of a [ __ ] there's a couple
different game modes to play in this Bo
hey stop preemptively gooing Roo hey you
want some you want some goo what were
you running from ah well that that's
what you were running from oh is it
boy do you oh god damn it I gotta get
one more kill it's one more delicious
kill with my goo goo oh oh hey Ike where
the hell yeah I'm towards the bottom I
didn't do good but hey I did something
and that's the best that I could
possibly hope for
yay so that was this complete deathmatch
and that was absolutely chaotic and I'm
not gonna play that again bloop
I said disconnect if kill me act there
we go so there's a lot of different
stuff that you can do I'm assuming I
have no idea I've never played the
goddamn game I wasn't even using my
goddamn grenades I like the goo gun I
guess it's goo goo for me and then
there's probably other things that you
can do as far as
unlocks I guess oh my god that's a lot
of unlocks see for a game being free
this is actually pretty amazing but this
thing on the beginning of the menu that
says get mooring man premium kind of
speaks to me that it might not be
entirely free so I'm gonna try capture
the flag now which obviously is debase
capture the flag and I'm assuming I'm
gonna be on the winning team and I'm
gonna do great with my goo who knows
whar Magoo
everybody wants goo on their team yeah I
don't even know the layout of the map
and I don't even know how I'm gonna do
I'm red okay so red is me there red - oh
that that's that's not go go go go goo
goo I help I help with that go go go
hey no one's as good as goo gone as I am
uh-huh Oh Oh God
hey what is he doing he's a lagger flag
Spiker
not fair okay there's got to be a way
around or else there's gonna be
absolutely nothing oh hey oh good you're
on my team I was almost gonna do you in
the face I mean maybe later
well let's talk about this first Oh Shh
what what what happened what happened I
don't know what happened to me I must
have bitten very almost dead oh man this
game just started okay
i'ma try what did I get switch teams how
do I switch teams whoa God oh geez
I drop my weapon Oh God let give me back
my goo gun I don't know how to switch
weapons just yet for this I gotta go in
there and I got a goo everyone in the
face oh the fool the man flag taken I
don't know what that whoa hey whoa goo
goo
haha you didn't expect all the goo what
is this I don't know this is please be
relived whoa God I did it Oh interior
design expert barbed wire here gonna
resupply somehow I don't know how to do
this I don't know how to do this laughs
oh gosh is so fun this game is
ridiculous
on that night yeah please get to only
use a combat knife because I'm a badass
yeah I've had enough doing people in the
face for one lifetime which was ha ha
chords to get some I've got a whole load
of some for someone to get anybody wants
them some I got a lot of it who wants it
hee hee oh god that's a bomb isn't it
yeah ok I'm just gonna drop on him oh my
god there's my face uh Oh God I got
destroyed there really quickly ok so
there's gotta be I gotta be able to get
down there and then yeah yeah it's gonna
be good it's gonna be goo yeah let me
Adam let me um let me Adam yeah ok this
is probably not the best way to go
I imagine was that oh cool I got
regeneration ha quantum huh you awesome
I got you yeah ok I got somebody
ah hey I can't believe this working ah
ah man that is probably not the best
idea I'm gonna switch out to do that I'm
gonna have the knife I'm just now gonna
use the knife to the best of my ability
let's see try the skin here come in all
heal to kill jhalak if I just start
spraying bullets oh god that was
actually a good move I didn't know that
he was there but I'm gonna assume that
he was or I'm an act like I assumed that
he was because I'm amazing it's called
the spray-and-pray method not quite as
similar to the pull and pray method but
very Oh God
want some I got a whole lot of some I
got a bucket full of some you want some
hey I mean you got no pie I got you I'm
gonna get you all ah damn it
uh uh uh no one expects you to come in
swinging with a knife it just usually
doesn't work out hasn't worked out for
me yet but just the fact that it usually
doesn't work out I'm coming in all
Hilter killed her yeah yeah
yes mm-hmm
I'm gonna get you you think that they
can escape their death
well they cannot they cannot I'm gonna
get this regeneration yeah then they're
never gonna be able to kill me I'm a
deaf floating towards them very slowly
but persistently come here
I got spinning that doesn't allow this
baby that's a lot of death Jesus what do
they have like a multi like a minigun
shotgun is nothing but shotgun shells
oh geez it's not even fair all right
we're gonna try this a little
differently maybe with a little bit less
stupid and hold more a lot of strategy
now I'm gonna switch to my knife they're
never gonna see it coming they think
whoa that markiplier got he probably
knows that that method doesn't work but
I'm gonna do it anyway good let me go
yeah
you're never gonna expect me yeah yeah
the man flag you've been taken good
oh Jesus I did not know there was a
turret there uh-uh-uh-uh-uh but I killed
him I killed him hey hurts it hurts a
lot
it hurts a lot whoa this is out of ammo
this was a mistake
oh this is a harpoon gun oh I did not
know that well I guess so much for being
sneaky peeky let's do this straight up
bruh
straight up breath oh god yeah oh god he
got some of this but he's dead too so
that's good was this oh that looks good
I guess is this another version of the
guqin cuz I sure do love splattering my
goo all over the enemy whoa that guy had
a lot of stuff meatball of doom but now
he's dead yummy here I shall wait who
he'll never see me coming
I can't use this underwater just gonna
don't mind me
don't mind me don't mind me ah come here
you oh jeez got me I should have just
sat down there would have been fine but
I had to confront him mano a mano as a
test of my incredible manliness
I mean we're gonna win we're already up
and there's only 245 left
I'm helping I'm a team player
I'm almost got them joy everybody did I
get one oh god I kill myself well that
should be understandable I was too
talented so I needed to remove myself
from the equation before the enemy got
too suspicious of my epic skills oh no
oh no no he don't
oh yes he does barely dad that guy was
off like a bullet oh geez oh gosh oh
gosh oh good okay we're fine
hello sir I'm gonna come down oh I was
gonna come get him ah oh geez
that guy's either good or maybe he's one
of these hacker types if people are
talking about Oh out of bullets hey whoo
yeah I have no idea where I see I am yes
I got 19 kills you know in 15 - whoo Wow
okay so that was boring man that was a
ton of fun and as far as I know this
game is completely free I don't even
think it's like one of those
free-to-play games I think it's just one
of those games that is free and super
duper fun so check it out for yourselves
there might be some hackers involved I
don't know but it's still fun so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
the link in the description below the
link to the game and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
yeah [ __ ] kid
thank you know